all right so Melania Trump has been in
the news a lot lately I was talking
about her in the monologue and she's on
the cover of Us Weekly with this cover
at my side of the story but they left
out my favorite feature in US Weekly
which is the 25 things you don't know
about me do you read about this all the
stars do it a Tim Gunn has done it if
you have his he'll be out here in a
minute and I did it it's practically a
rite of passage you have mine there you
go and we got ahold of Milania see it's
not in this magazine but it's coming out
so would you like to hear Milania is 25
days in Slovenia I was a catalog model
which is what you call a model you order
out of a catalog
[Applause]
I have no first language I hope I
inspire little girls everywhere to marry
for money that's every time I look at my
husband I'm reminded of the Slovenian
national dish greasy sausage drove with
cheeks
[Applause]
I once caught Mike Pence trying on my
stilettos well
My Secret Service code name is that poor
poor woman I copied this list from
Michelle Obama
sometimes when I bounce light off my
diamond
Donald's Harry will chase it like a cat
I wish I knew why I have a recurring
dream I'm pinned beneath a giant orange
sack of and if I could tell my
younger self just one thing it would be
this if you catch a leprechaun and it
gives you one wish be more specific